After another huge brawl and face-off, the
ending of Cobra Kai Season 5 leaves the future
of John Kreese's karate dojo in enormous doubt
and perhaps signals the imminent end of the
series itself.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining how Cobra Kai's
fifth season could be setting up a big twist
in Season 6, plus I'll be revealing the little
details and easter eggs you might have missed
in the season 5 finale.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
Season 5 ends with a smashing show-down as
Daniel triumphs over Silver, crane-kicking
him through a giant glass cobra.
As Silver's students line up to quit and throw
off their Cobra Kai shirts in disgust after
the revelation their sensei bribed the referee
at the All Valley Tournament in Season 4,
it appears that Cobra Kai's days may truly
be numbered.
Interestingly, Daniel defeats the sneaky sensei
by employing against him the Quick Silver
rules that Silver taught him in Karate Kid
3.
This is exactly what Chozen recommended to
Daniel in the very first episode.
To catch serpent, you must think like serpent.
We will use his style against him.
Daniel's victory here shows he's been willing
to embrace other karate styles in addition
to those he learned from Mr Miyagi, something
he admitted to Johnny at the end of Season
4 when he saw his own daughter using some
of Eagle Fang's moves at the tournament.
I see some of what you teach can be good sometimes.
This continues the overarching Cobra Kai series
theme of former foes reconciling and then
making something new by blending their contrasting
attitudes and styles of karate together,
We've combined our different styles to train
our students into the best fighters I've ever
seen.
By the way, notice that how Daniel lands his
final blow on Silver by crane-kicking him
into the glass cobra on the wall behind him
is a call-back to when Silver fell into a
pane of glass during his fight with Mr Miyagi
in The Karate Kid 3, as well as to Daniel's
winning kick to take out the young Cobra Kai
star Johnny in the original movie.
But let's not forget the crucial part the
Miyagi-Do students also played in taking down
Silver.
After uncovering the incriminating footage
of Tory's talk with her sensei, they remembered
Chozen's training and advice to work together
as a team against the onslaught of Cobra Kai.
He said that the snakes will take us down
one by one.
But what if we weren't a bunch of ones?
The only way we win is if we work together.
Similar to how, together, they surrounded
the basket of eggs to protect it against Chozen,
they formed a barrier around Anthony and the
tablet which was uploading the incriminating
clip of Silver.
So, by the end of Season 5, with the exception
of Kreese – more on him shortly – the
biggest Cobra Kai and Miyagi-Do rivalries
appear to have been resolved for both the
OG Karate Kid characters and the new generation.
Miguel and Robbie are now friends;
Sam and Tory are reconciled and fought together
against Sensei Kim, with Devon also abandoning
Cobra Kai to join them;
Oh, I will be a champion.
But I'll get there my way, not yours.
meanwhile Kenny's beef with Robbie seems to
have been put aside;
and even Stingray redeems himself when he
comes to rescue Daniel.
What are you doing?
It's pitch black out.
Stingrays see better in the dark.
But with Silver hauled off by the police,
what's left now for the series and the Cobra
Kai legacy he repeatedly spoke about in Season
5?
I never had any children.
My only legacy is Cobra Kai.
Well, conveniently in Season 5 we're introduced
to the granddaughter of Master Kim, who Silver
invited over from Korea to join him at Cobra
Kai.
I did not get on the plane for money.
What I'm offering you is legacy.
Your grandfather didn't teach American soldiers
the Way of the Fist just to use on the battlefield.
We have to share his style with the world.
As a child, she avidly watched the young Kreese
and Silver train with her grandfather, and
she's clearly motivated to make her own mark
in the martial arts world now.
Silver may be arrested, but Cobra Kai as a
dojo was already accepted to compete at the
Sekai Taikai international tournament, and
if she wanted she could recruit her own students,
perhaps from Korea, and enter the competition
under the Cobra Kai name, thus continuing
the legacy of Cobra Kai, fulfilling what Silver
predicted:
Cobra Kai will go on forever.
Though, of course, it's also possible that
she'd want to distance herself from the bad
publicity surrounding Silver and his dojo.
The Sekai Taikai tournament will undoubtedly
be the focus of Season 6, and it seems more
than likely that Sensei Kim will be competing
there in some form or another bringing her
grandfather's "Way of the Fist" style of fighting
to the competition, and setting up a clash
with the karate styles championed by Daniel
and Johnny at Miyagi-Do and Eagle Fang.
Chozen also revealed that his uncle Sato,
the secondary villain from Karate Kid 2, had
major beef with Master Kim and I expect a
lot of that history will be revealed in Season
6, setting up a collision between Chozen and
Sensei Kim.
My uncle Sato did not speak much of Kim Sun-Yung.
But I know he had much anger towards him.
Chozen also revealed that Master Kim's teachings
are behind a lot of Cobra Kai's brutal philosophy.
Kim Sun-Yung's style is based on deception.
No honor.
No mercy.
Of course, John Kreese, the OG big bad of
the original Karate Kid film, will be back
to mix things up in Season 6 after faking
his own death yet again.
The finale began with Kreese pretending he
was done with everything after being tricked
by his former star student Johnny and arch
enemy Daniel, and telling Tory to look after
herself from now on and forget about him.
And his opening words in the final episode…
This is it.
End of the line.
…are a call-back to what Danny's mum said
to her teen son when they first arrived in
LA, the event that kicked off the whole Karate
Kid and Cobra Kai saga.
This is it.
This is the end of the line.
That's a clever little signal that although
Kreese claims he's giving up, this moment
is really just the beginning of a new chapter
in his life, just like it was for Daniel all
those years ago.
Now that an unrepentant Kreese has broken
out of prison, it'll be interesting to see
how he reacts to Silver's arrest and discovering
that the students from his beloved dojo have
abandoned it.
The threat that Johnny made to wipe out Kreese's
legacy appears to have come true.
You wanna know why I'm in this fight?
So I can erase everything you did.
And every mark you left.
Every memory of you.
I expect Kreese might well team up with Sensei
Kim when he discovers she's been at Cobra
Kai.
Remember from the flashback that they both
seemed to get along with each other when they
were younger, and this will be Kreese's opportunity
to re-establish the legacy of Cobra Kai which,
of course, came from Kim's grandfather.
On top of that, going up against Daniel and
Johnny at the international tournament will
be a chance for him to get revenge on them
for the trick they pulled on him in prison.
I think Kreese will also be looking to get
his own personal payback on Silver for framing
him for beating up Stingray.
First of all, I'm not entirely convinced Silver
will be going to jail.
He's got plenty of money to pay the best lawyers
around, and they could probably convince a
jury that Stingray's new testimony is unreliable
given he already lied about Kreese.
Plus, the video evidence of Silver beating
up Stingray has already been deleted.
If Silver does go free then, Kreese will likely
want his own revenge.
There is an endgame, kid.
Silver's going down.
Only he doesn't know it yet.
Now, Season 6 hasn't been confirmed by Netflix
yet, but apparently some scenes have already
been filmed;
however, my feeling is that it could well
be the final season of the series.
Many major character arcs have already been
wrapped up in Season 5, and it's hard to see
how exactly the series could carry on and
top the stakes of the biggest karate tournament
in the world.
It also makes me wonder whether there could
be a big surprise twist for the final season,
and I think there's a clue in the Season 5
moment when Daniel and Johnny were accepted
into the tournament and were asked for the
name of their dojo…
We just need your dojo's name.
We are Miyagi-Do.
And we are Eagle Fang.
Well, which is it?
Now, wild and out-there theory time, folks,
but what if Johnny and Daniel decide they
want to finally rehabilitate Cobra Kai by
taking on the mantle themselves, so that Miyagi-Do
and Eagle Fang combine to become the new Cobra
Kai, or Miyagi-Cobra-Fang?
It was Johnny after all who resurrected Cobra
Kai, and it would be an intriguing turn of
events for the OG Karate Kid to rehabilitate
the dojo of his former nemesis.
He did already of course train at Silver's
Cobra Kai in the third movie, and used some
of those techniques this season to defeat
Silver.
The biggest problem with this idea is that
it may be hard for Daniel to justify it as
fitting in with and honouring Mr Miyagi's
legacy.
Of course, the whole name thing may just be
a bit of fun and a meta moment alluding to
how fans have referred to Daniel and Johnny's
team up in earlier seasons as "Miyagi-Fang",
something also acknowledged by Stingray when
he gets ambushed.
Miyagi-Fangs?
Overall, I feel that Season 6 might be the
best way to end the Cobra Kai series on a
relatively high note, rather than dragging
things out for many more seasons.
So, what do you think?
Did you enjoy Season 5 and do you think the
series is ready to wrap things up for good
in Season 6?
You can tap here for more Cobra Kai videos
with easter eggs and details you missed.
And if you liked this video, do leave a thumbs-up,
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for enjoying Cobra Kai with me and
hope you have a marvellous movie-loving week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!